[Music]
I assure you brother The Sun will shine
on us again
we're optimism is misplaced has gone
well the one thing I'm not Asgardian and
for another we have a hot
let him have his fun
[Music]
in all the time I've served that I have
never failed
if I were to reach our rendezvous on
Titan with the time stem still attached
to your vaguely irritating person there
would be
[Music]
hey everybody its charlie we have a
whole bunch of infinity war that's
dropping as requested I'll just post
stuff as it comes I really wasn't
expecting a lot of this stuff to start
hitting until the end of July when the
digital release is going to happen and
if you are brand new to the channel I
will be doing blu-ray giveaways for the
rest of the year every week so all you
have to do to enter that is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
video but the Russos themselves
confirmed that there would be way more
deleted scenes on this blu-ray than they
have done in previous Marvel films like
Winter Soldier or Captain America Civil
War because there was so many different
pairings so they had to do so much more
improv so way more stuff ended up
hitting the cutting room floor and it
wasn't bad like watching Robert Downey
jr. and Benedict Cumberbatch improv
scenes with each other was awesome but
of course there wasn't that many scenes
with them together so a lot of that had
to hit the cutting room floor so this is
a clip of them explaining that then I'll
talk a little bit about Loki's art
because there been a lot of theories
about what's going on with his character
through these next two Avengers films
the Sun will shine on us again brother
lots of out on the secrecy around as
well in particular and I've heard tale
of um secret scenes and ending on fight
scenes and endings and people scripts
that's right did you have some fun doing
that it's more work because you know
it's already hard enough to just get the
real script in order um in terms of sort
of deleted scenes and extras because
these films are so jam-packed anyway can
we expect some extra scenes I think so I
mean I think in particular you know we
were very tight with the scripts I'm
Winter Soldier in civil war so there
weren't a lot of extras this is a very
big movie with a lot of characters in it
and we played around with a lot of
improvisation because we had new
chemistry that we were defining between
characters where you know we've you know
that's the first time ever that all
these characters are on-screen together
so we played around with quite a bit of
footage and I think I think there'll be
some good stuff for the DVD Easter eggs
I mean these films are always packed
with with so many things is there
anything to look out for you
particularly please I mean I think you
know it's you know the crew is complicit
in these Easter eggs with us they're all
very aware of them are
ethology from our prop team to our stunt
team so I think there's lots of little
Easter eggs I would say to our Arrested
Development fans that they should keep
their eyes open I think it's pretty
accurate to say I speak for everyone
when we say just give us all of the
deleted scenes I can only imagine how
many hours and hours of footage that
they have that they could release with
that blu-ray so hopefully they're
deciding all that we don't know exactly
which scenes they're gonna be putting on
it usually find out about that when it
gets a little bit closer to release but
getting into the low-key theory a lot of
people are wondering if he's not really
dead if this is just more sleight of
hand because he does tell Thor very
confidently that the Sun will shine on
us again like he's saying that this
might suck but something better is right
around the corner like wait a minute are
you coming back later how is this going
to happen because then Thanos counters
with no resurrections this time which I
think was a line of dialogue that they
specifically included to let you know
that he was dying in this moment so if
he really did die then how is he coming
back because he was definitely filmed on
the set of Avengers 4 when they were
doing those flashback scenes Loki is the
god of mischief the Lord of misrule an
agent of chaos chaos isn't something
that's threatening to Loki and
[Music]
everything's fine now we call them
flashback scenes but there are a lot of
different things that could be happening
here because this is just the original
Battle of New York during the first
Avengers film I've already done a couple
videos based on what the Russos have
said because we do know there's gonna be
some time-travel elements in the film
they'll be a bit of a time jump when
Avengers 4 picks up but the Russos
themselves said that these moments here
are mostly the BAA are effing technology
which means mostly then bringing Loki
back because it's through their memories
of him not physical Loki coming back
just in these moments that doesn't mean
the Loki won't pop up in some other way
but people came out of the theater after
infinity war and they're like you know
Loki's attack with those daggers that
was weak he probably knew that that
wouldn't work so it was some ruse but I
think there were a couple things that
were going on in this moment one I think
that he was stalling for time so that
Heimdall could rally and send Hulk away
so that he could warn everyone that
Thanos was coming but also to you'll
remember that the infinity war
screenwriters were asked about what
happened
to Valkyrie Korg meek in the other half
of the Asgardians because they say only
about half of the Asgardians that were
on the ship at the end of thor ragnarok
died in this moment here so the other
reason why I think that Loki is doing
this knowing that he's going to be
killed is to buy more time for them to
escape because they're basically like
well Valkyrie you know wasn't in the
movie but she and Korg helped the other
half of those as Guardians escape so
Asgard isn't a place it's a people they
escaped Asgard still exists that
explains why Thor still has his power
although a lot of that is based on the
way that the screenwriters write the
characters so the screenwriters did own
up to the fact that if some of the
characters felt weird than they did in
the previous films like the guardians
characters felt a little bit different
than they did in guardians to when James
Gunn was writing them they said that
that was mostly on them like we wanted
them to do certain things so we wrote
them this way so when you rewatch
infinity war if there are moments where
you feel like characters are acting out
of character or things are weird that's
just because that's what the infinity
war people wanted to do with that movie
so for those of you holding out hope
that Loki had been masquerading his
banner and that's why he couldn't Hulk
out they already explained what was
going on with the Hulk I've done a
couple videos about that so I'll post
links for that at the end of this short
answer is is that Hulk was being a dick
during infinity war because banner only
wants hope for fighting like he feels
underappreciated so we could talk all
day about weirdness logical
inconsistencies but that's just what
they're doing with that character so
Hulk will be back in Avengers 4 I've
also done separate videos about that
because he will be wearing some really
badass armor from the comics if you
haven't read a whole lot of Hulk the
last couple of years a whole lot of
Avengers titles there have been various
points at which Hulk has worn armor worn
clothes we've been talking a lot about
Professor Hulk so just keep your mind
open for that obviously there's gonna be
a whole bunch of Avenger stuff happening
when they do drop it on digital so I
think what'll happen is is because
they're skipping Hall H in the infinity
war blu-ray is dropping the week after
comic-con is the bookend and Avengers 4
title later this year then we'll get a
teaser I think we'll drop everything at
the same time they're gonna try and turn
each little piece of information into a
big PR event like we're going to
reveal the title soon and that will be
like them dropping a big trailer but
then later in the year they'll drop an
actual teaser with new footage so for
those of you that are really hoping that
Loki comes back remember there's a
multiverse there are many different
realities in which he could still be
alive
there's time-travel elements so there's
ways for them to give him more scenes
and closure with the Thor character
without rolling back his sacrifice in
this moment because I think when Thanos
says no resurrections that's meant to be
final what'll happen is is Kevin Feige
confirmed that ant-man the wasp connects
to Avengers 4 so I'll do a video for
that next they'll probably be some more
Marvel later this weekend my Luke Cage
video this is a bunch of stuff dropping
so as long as you have alerts enabled
for my channel you'll see all the videos
should be fine but congratulations to a
cave productions you're the latest
giveaway winner please private message
me so I can get your contact details
click here to learn all about what's
going on with the Fox Disney deal and
click here for that whole video thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]